I thought we best start with a demo in Power BI where I
can introduce these concepts a bit more concretely.
That way, when we're going through these in the abstract,
you'll have something specific to associate them with.
Now to begin, it's important to understand that in Power BI,
data sources once selected and get data become queries,
and once loaded and are transferred in Power Query become tables.
Let's take a brief peek at the data in Power Query first.
I can show you very briefly using the produce query that
I've already taken several applied steps on the right to clean up the data a bit.
What I really want you to focus on here is the three query names here;
produce, sales, and store calendar.
They're all the same as what we just saw here on the reporting pane: produce,
sales, store calendar,
and they'll repeat when we look at the data pane which is here.
Produce, sales, store calendar,
same information but represented as tables rather than queries,
and then reflected again in the data modeling pane.
If you've seen a Power BI presentation in the past,
you may have seen that the visual is generally interact.
But here we have
three different data sources on
the right-hand side of the reporting pane as we looked at before,
and it's obvious they're not interacting as they should.
Normally, if I select items on this Treemap,
say if I select herbs,
this card showing the subtotal of sales would
give me just the subtotal sum of sales for herbs.
Instead, it's showing our sub-total sales for all products with no change,
and that remains true no matter what I select.
There's something else odd here as well.
Treemaps are a little like square pie charts if you're not familiar with them.
The area they take up represents their share of
a value and in this case, that's also subtotal.
You would generally expect to see different sizes of boxes representing how much
of each product type makes up the total subtotal for those sales.
Of course, the reason nothing in this report is working is because we're referencing
data from three different tables and I've
deliberately avoided setting up the relationship.
Let's go back to the model pane and fix that.
Here in the middle is my fact table.
This includes all of my sales transactions.
We'll go into this in greater detail later in the lesson,
but the fact table holds facts or things that happen.
If you look at this table up close,
you can imagine a grocery store clerk ringing up each of your purchases one by one.
Each of these would become its own row in a table like this one.
Now let's go back to the diagram.
Do you see that there's a PLU column listed right there on the sales table,
and then if we go over to the produce table,
there is a corresponding PLU column here as well?
Once we tie these two PLU columns together,
we create a relationship,
because both of these are what we call key columns.
Now all of the additional descriptive information that's available on
the produce dimension table is available to provide
additional details about those sales transactions,
and we'll do the same thing for our store calendar.
Date column, which is our key column for the stock calendar.
Date column on the sales fact table are now tied together.
We have two relationships for our three tables.
If we go back to the report,
we're now able to use all that useful information from the dimension tables to
augment the fact tables and that's reflected in the Treemap here.
You can see that the relationships are feeding in and working.
If we select the herb section of the Treemap,
you can see in the subtotal right here,
we're getting a true subtotal for herbs rather than the total for everything.
You can do that with fruits and vegetables as well.
We're now seeing a proportion of subtotal of
sales by produce of category just as we wanted.
We'll get into data clean up in upcoming lessons but for now,
we're going to focus on nailing down
the foundational concepts of fact tables, dimension tables,
and keys so that when you've got your own datasets all cleaned up,
creating your own connections will be just as quick and easy.